the Trump administration is urging all
countries to cut ties with North Korea
after its newest missile test a video
released overnight shows Wednesday's
launch of that intercontinental
ballistic missile analysts say that it
is capable of striking anywhere in the
United States American UN Ambassador
nikki Haley says this test brings the
world closer to war she warned that
North Korea would be utterly destroyed
if war comes Ben Tracy's in Tokyo
following their reaction they are been
good morning good morning the only two
countries that have any real ties to
North Korea are Russia and China and
today Russia flat-out rejected president
Trump's call to sever ties with Kim Jong
Un's regime they want the u.s. to try
diplomacy even though North Korea seems
more intent on testing missiles than
talking as North Korea's most advanced
missile launched into the night sky a
beaming Kim jong-un was clearly pleased
with his regimes accomplishment the
Hassan 15 rocket is the third ICBM
launch by North Korea in the past six
months the dictator of North Korea made
a choice yesterday that brings the world
closer to war not farther from it at an
emergency meeting of the United Nations
Security Council US ambassador nikki
Haley issued a stark warning about what
she calls North Korea's continued acts
of aggression if war comes make no
mistake the North Korean regime will be
utterly destroyed
the Trump administration is calling on
China North Korea's main trading partner
to entirely cut off the regime's oil
supply little Rocketman president Trump
made fun of Kim Jong moon during a
speech outside st. Louis on tax reform
is a sick puppy but experts who have
studied photos of the regime's new
weapon are taking it very seriously I
think it's clear from the pictures that
it's a more capable rocket than
certainly than the last one we saw David
Wright of the Union of Concerned
Scientists says he's surprised by how
fast North Korea is advancing its
missile program I'm less skeptical than
I might have been that they can deliver
a warhead to certainly the west coast
and maybe maybe larger parts of the
United States so I think the threat that
they had been talking about is or the
real threat at this point after this
latest missile launch North Dakota has
declared that it has completed its
nuclear weapons program state media
there says kim jeong-hoon said it was
such a milestone it should be recorded
in the nation's history Nora
Ben Tracy thank you for continuing to
follow this story thank you